so you don't think you don't think
that's appropriate just to kind of put
that you don't think that's an
appropriate uh
thing to do for a company to say if i
bring you 22 500 jobs
at 150 000 your income give me some tax
breaks you don't think that's the right
thing to do it's what you're saying
well i think we have to be careful i i
think that i i i
i'm not sure there's a general rule but
i think what we have to look at is what
are the trade-offs in new york city
actually
won the contract with amazon and then
decided that they weren't going to
accept it because it was a bad deal for
them
so if you give the company such tax
breaks but
i don't think new york city said no
though i think aoc campaigned around it
saying the fact that the rent's going to
go up and
both de blasio and uh uh
uh uh what's the governor's name uh
cuomo but
the palacio cuomo wanted it but aoc's
campaign drove bezos away and bezos
finally said i'm not gonna put it here
so
new york wanted it but aoc kind of
pushed them away
well yeah who does aoc represent you
know i mean
obviously she's a she's a a big
supporter of the socialistic philosophy
and cuomo de blasio kind of wanted those
jobs in new york
and you would think that cuomo and and
bellatio would be
more powerful than her wouldn't you
actually i mean they
they've got the big corporations behind
them i don't think so i think because
nowadays you know one of your talks you
gave which was very powerful you said
uh i don't know if it was your tedx or i
don't know which uh interview you did
you talked about the fact that the power
people have today to send emails to
companies to talk about the fact that
hey
let's do more social let's give back to
community let's use our power and
resources to
send an email people are listening
nowadays there's this thing that email
today called twitter
well aoc has nearly 8 million twitter
followers that's more than both of them
combined times 10
you know times uh six so you have to
realize that it's
it's different today just because you're
a mayor of new york or governor new york
doesn't mean you have more influence
than somebody that's a congressman
with eight million followers one's got a
bigger voice than the rest do
and is that democracy in the works
i mean it's called marketing to me it's
not democracy
there's always been there's always been
a fine line there hasn't there between
in any case you know i don't know you
know who's right or wrong but the point
being
that you know do you bring a company in
and offer them huge tax breaks
but at the same time you give them huge
benefits in terms of the school system
the fire departments the police
departments the sewage systems
all these other things that the company
benefits from the airports
do do they pay their fair share and
that's a question i think every
community has to
ask itself and we see the same thing in
countries so we've got
a company going in and talking to
indonesia saying hey if you let us build
our next plant here
uh and we will build our next plant here
if you'll give us big tax breaks
and if you don't we'll go to the
philippines and
these countries you know always have to
look at this and and nine times out of
ten in my experience
it's the wealthy people who benefit so
you give the company the tax
breaks and the wealthy people somehow
end up getting the kind of deals that i
described where their brothers get these
contracts and their system
and so on and so forth so but i think
you know that's why i say i don't think
there's a general answer to your
question i mean tax breaks can be used
very very wisely
but they can also be a very corrupt form
of of
companies getting things for free that
they probably should be paying for
and i also think patrick an argument
could be made to let's not tax
corporations at all
but let's let's really tax the people
who benefit from them the stockholders
especially the wealthiest stockholders
who
pay their fair share i mean there's so
many different ways to look at this
whole
process of how do we how do we support
our police forces and our fire
departments and our hospitals and our
schools
and our utility companies who who pays
who pays the price for these things i
mean
listen we're going into a whole
different conversation because if you if
you think about that part
you know i'd much rather have amazon go
to new york and go to dc
because if you go to dc that's the
ultimate crony capitalism business model
where you are now in the
you know you you know what it costs to
senators pass the law nowadays i think
it's fifty thousand dollars to a hundred
thousand dollars
doesn't cost that much money to do some
of that so you know if they go to new
york and then i think from the
governor's standpoint like i moved my
business from la to here
okay when i moved here i brought all the
jobs here
and you know every uh a race
everything that we did texas got the
benefit of the people that are living
here whether they bought homes they get
their kids sent to kids to private
school
all the money they spent at the market
you know gas
all of that stuff texas benefit from it
california lost from it right and you've
seen a lot of that with elon musk just
put his plant in um austin so i'm i'm
just thinking economically how that
makes sense
for some states i understand the benefit
of having twenty two thousand five
hundred jobs painted on an average of a
hundred fifty thousand 000
bring it to my city i'd love to find a
way to make it work with you if i'm a
governor
or mayor at that time but